gummy
stick around make a sound there's more
don't people another episode of dumb
people Town population
you're in the third incarnation of
yourself so many dumb art third life
Dumb articles have been written we've
had the Good Fortune of sitting down for
The Misfortune I really stunk at
something that would be your drag name
Misfortune that's mine
I thought you were Mr Fortune um
yeah so uh we are here in our new studio
it's the First episodes with all things
done that's right and the batch of the
new we're on the new Set uh you can
watch this on uh YouTube you can thank
you for tuning in on YouTube yeah if
you're tuning in and watching this um
this nice set they have it is so cool so
I'm gonna encourage you Hey listen to it
on wherever you listen to your podcast
and then go watch it it's just fun we're
excited to be in our new digs and try
this out and so of course we called up
some of our favorite people that we've
ever had on this podcast to come and
help us in Fortune you're here you
understand the world of dumb I do you
get it on such a dumb and me right
thank you take someone to no one
all right I'll have a little bit we do
different things I love like we just saw
a set that you did on stage and you just
talked about a few dumb things that you
did and your attitude towards the dumb
stuff you do is just so it's so funny I
was just the second you make it okay
dumb you definitely like give people
permission to be like yeah you were
talking about Alaska ghosts and haunting
and just you acting stupid about it and
it was making me laugh so hard oh that's
nice I love this stuff I'm trying to
work out my special came out and I gotta
write a whole new Max yeah well here's
the deal we're gonna help with this
let's just riff because who knows
something may come out of this we get
this show gives you the material you
don't have to use scrub sticks together
we go here we go so Dan we get story
sent to us I guess Twitter is still a
thing
is it still happening right now as of
right now as I found out even if I leave
Twitter
uh I can still search it sure so you can
always do it hashtag dumb people Town
Square Brothers at Daniel Van Kirk and
that's how we get our story send them to
us let's jump in Dan we've got a person
than me would probably go with Discord
but I don't 100 know what that I don't
know what that is Twitch it's not for
lack of ability it's for lack of trying
lack of understanding here we go ready
yes we are uh this was sent in by Jake
groney at jaycaroney thanks buddy inmate
steals bike in escape attempt
so in the prison takes what I think it
was in the prison I think part of their
escaping was with a bike you said an
inmate stole a bike in while trying to
escape prison but I think they were
already out here we go okay Nashville
Tennessee okay right yes Music City
Music this is the Music City Miracle
we'll find out there are no flags on the
field I should probably know this
Chatham Chatham even though it looks
like Cheatham chat even though it looks
like cheat ham it's Chatham so Mike it
is
my kids when they were little had these
little like
are they Guinea they they weren't live
but they were like these little stuffed
animals that had a little voice thing in
that when you press the Paw yeah they
were called chathamels oh I don't know
I'd bring this up because
yeah the best thing about them is like
you press it and you don't know if
you're gonna get the super high voice or
the low one so like we used to walk it
super high hey now but you just press
the hand like there my kids would like
be at school and I would just press it
and be like charitable they would say
what they are Shadow well the Chatham
County Sheriff's Office is trying to
return a bike to its owner and due to
its size and appearance officers believe
the bike belongs to a little girl wait
what if it was one of those dumb ass
bikes pink bikes no I'm talking about
the ones that people ride that have that
are like super tall have you ever seen
those like the seat is sorry like the
king of the douchebag you're like oh
okay I like a one of those beer parades
I've seen these people
let me pedal for my yeah that's very
natural
Dan I'm talking about the super high I
know I know exactly yeah so there's like
a
the what is it called
Penny foreign
so the idea is like the only reason you
have a bike like that because you want
people to pay attention to people that
ask you like how do you get up on that
thing well I gotta stand on a wall and
then I you know this first of all first
first uh point of something
parliamentary procedure yes we I want to
get a little baby monitor for Aaron out
here so that at any point or even a
walkie-talkie walkie-talkie's probably
even walkie-talkie yeah we're at any
point if you can go it's a goddamn Penny
Farm any Farthing I've never heard from
BBC no the penny um
I think is a small town priest in
Scotland who solves crimes on people I
would watch that right after Rick Steves
crime 100 don't you a priest you're like
wait a minute you shouldn't be drinking
like that shitty yeah
okay so they think that the bike that
they have here yeah the guy stole
belongs to a little girl investigator
said last week and escaped in my inmate
was caught on the side of the road
awkwardly speed pedaling a small bike so
they didn't go that fast on those legs
going like this some giant like Aryan
dude and a wife beat her with like
swastikas
so hard you're almost better on foot
he's like going backwards right it was a
good it's a good idea in principle yeah
I saw a tick tock video of a guy who bet
another guy that he couldn't get off the
bus and run to the next stop in time to
catch the bus by the way how has no one
thought of this bad this is the greatest
show ever doors open he gets out runs
yeah runs as fast as he can and then you
see the bus start to catch up with him
I'm like oh he's toast but then you
don't realize that the stop isn't that
far away yeah and he gets there and he's
out of breath and he made it and I'm
like this gives me Faith in humanity the
story takes away that pro move is get in
front of the bus oh yeah but then you're
gonna find out what type of bus driver
someone who's drinking on the job in
Chicago like along State Street the
stops are so frequent on the red line I
did have times where I got down there
and it was just taking off and I
sprinted you can just run from one stop
for like two or three stops you can
essentially just run from one stop to
them that's great a victory
um okay investigators said the inmate
traveled
investigators said the inmate traveled
at least how many miles before getting
caught so on a children's book
pedaling for his five miles life five
miles that's so far
Jesus by the way five miles on a bike is
not five miles away that's a degenerate
marathon and iron a degenerate Iron Man
five miles on a kid's bike five miles on
a kid's bike do you know how much
rotations
because the other side to y5 would be
good is like how fast and hard and far
would you pedal to not go back to jail I
mean you really don't want to go back to
yourself I got five five on it you got
five I'm gonna say this should have been
a scene in Shawshank redempt right
exactly get rid of the and as he's
pedaling rocks from the yard come out of
his pants and you hear like Morgan
Freeman Andy Dufresne so I climbed
aboard the tiny bike
cost me two packs of cigarettes that
night it didn't make a sound it was a
child's back I don't have a I would try
but come on there's just one little
Morgan I'm Morgan Freeman
yeah every impression you do is you
announcing who you are I love it um
four miles four miles four miles four
chamber five I know what if it's five
we're gonna help you win okay one of you
one of us is right it's exactly right so
now we get together to play the game who
do you think is exactly right do you
want to stick with yourself I'm sticking
with myself I'm gonna stick with her
original answer
save me okay
uh get your answers in YouTubers write
it in the comments and then you can time
stamp that you were right again or just
yelling out wherever you are yelled at
your ham radio because he traveled
two miles
you stepped in you were in the batter's
box you took a swing then you stepped
out yeah hang on a second let me choke
up Aid in a bet we'll throw this um
we'll throw this picture up uh at the
end of YouTube and you can also get it
on social media and stuff like that but
this is this is the bike it says
it says La Jolla on it it is not built
for speech
and if you're the girl whose bike it is
are you like I need a new bike this has
now been dirtied by there's nothing
about this bike that indicates that it's
for a girl or a boy it's for someone who
wants to ride a bike someone who wants
to cruise right it's a cruising exactly
so they're trying to get it back to the
owner yes and I I hope they find some
guy they're like we've been looking for
a little girl this is my business
how do you gender assign my my 46 year
old accountants why am I this is my
favorite bike all his friends are like
uh is Jeff coming over is he gonna bring
his little girl bike or what's he gonna
do it's kind of little basket in the
front that was the most bizarre thing
Steven Ellis said they have not
indicated
why he was watching it it's the most
bizarre thing he had to weigh in on this
yeah what does Stephen Ellis think about
yeah right exactly the most bizarre
thing I've ever seen he says uh he said
he explained he did not think he'd be
the one to stop escaped inmate Ricky
roach okay so he must be a police oh
yeah yeah the inmate's name is Ricky
Rose yeah Dan Ricky roach to me feels
like the guy who hosted the head bangers
ball on it
like a guy who's like I'm friends with
all the Beastie Boys and I used to know
all of them forever
[Music]
Ricky roach does sell fake concert
tickets
100 Ricky roaches at work what if you
want a business of selling yeah so like
he collects from parties all the roaches
that aren't smoking and he connects them
with a little clip attached to a raccoon
do you think he calls himself the
Exterminator
quote I was in you can't kill me I'm
Ricky roach I was in as much shock as
anybody else would be when you look out
and see the person they are looking for
standing right in front of your mailbox
and you're thinking what's going on now
so this this cop's having his morning
coffee looking out the windows
or something we got someone on a kid's
bike and there he is a little girl's
bike a little tiny can you just hear in
the background and then what if Steve
Ellis is like that doesn't really look
like a girl's [__] yeah
it's like a beach cruiser guy with a
LoJack on his leg just pedaling really
would a girl have a beach cruiser I
don't know Alice is a reserve Deputy for
the Ashland City police last Thursday he
heard on his radio that roach was riding
down Ellis's Street on a bike I was in
the kitchen and I looked out the bay
window into my surprise okay humble brag
you have a bay window I could have just
said I looked out
what kind of a window was it you know I
I appeared over the bench the ample
bench seating yeah right well it was
sitting in the back what the well that's
the worst look ever to happen to be
rolling past a reserve cops window yeah
of all the windows and you are winded
and all the bay windows of all the bay
windows
I was sitting in my open concept kitchen
we just put an island in that's also a
bit of a breakfast nook I walked around
that next to the wolf
our bay window and all right there goes
through the garage I'm standing right
next to my Lexus lease and
okay he says I was in the kitchen out
the big window it's the guy we're
looking for roach was on the run for how
many hours at this point
two miles two miles but he's been on the
run before so there's time where he was
on the run before the bike I don't think
much though but I don't know
long as does it take to ride a mile on a
bike
I'm not great at this I don't think he
got out of jail found the bike and went
so I think he's been on the run for a
little bit but it's up to you I'm gonna
say he was on the run for
an hour okay five hours okay three hours
three hours roach was on the run for two
hours
finally he escaped from the hospital in
Ashland City and eventually picked up a
bicycle with
this is when I knew a bell on it no
he picked up a bicycle with only one
pedal oh
he's going in circles no but he must be
just on the floor on one one leg one leg
this goes back to what Fortune said
you're better off without the box at
some point
come on unless for him he was like Hey
if I ever get out of here I'm riding a
bike yeah that's right and also on foot
you can go into a is there a forest
there are people you're limited by the
bike in terms of what you can jump
around everyone knows when you escape
prison you find the nearest one yeah
Ellis said by the time roach made it
from the hospital to Bell Street which
is his house yeah on the bike he was
exhausted of course one leg hurt really
bad ready Lance Armstrong does it with
one ball this is my schedule with one
leg one pedal I told him to get down
Alice said and he and roach replied I'm
not gonna run anyway I'm tired of
running I'm just gonna lay here
[Laughter]
maybe there should be a test for anyone
that wants to escape prison they're like
we'll let you try right leave a one
pedal bike I mean there's people with
Alcatraz you didn't need any walls yeah
hey if you want to go for it yeah
or the water or the current or no one is
gonna get you one bike and then it just
that's where people stop so he just got
to the point where he was like I don't
care anymore so what they do I'd rather
lay down
and go back make housing this is the
Long play they make housing two miles
away from the prison really affordable
for Reserve police officers
you can like get a house and put a bag
in your kitchen look at that and so like
and they put a series of one pedal bikes
just outside and they're like go ahead
try this
wind up in front of some Reserve cops
house because this is the neighborhood
that they all live you just sold a show
to fuse TV yeah you don't even know it
Moran fuel TV yeah there you go called
reserved
called I've got reservations have you
guys ever seen this reminds me too like
I've seen this uh just small years
working in bars where like two guys will
get in a fight and if it goes on long
enough and thankfully no one gets like
really really hurt right they just get
so tired yeah they're just that they're
like I don't really wanna Dan dude you
can't even like you picture where
marathoners collapsing like this dude
was just like hey man imagine getting
punched isn't as cool as it looks in the
movie no it's not or the punching
probably yeah
there are times where I watch both like
bull riding and the bull will come out
of the gate
the ball just stands there it was like
all right I'm done we're done I did get
off my back so I can now go after a
clown yeah
uh the Chatham excuse me not a clown an
alcoholic nothing they spelled it
differently here in the beginning of
this story this was spelled c-h-e-a now
it's c-h-a-t Dan Chatham County is there
any faith in them I was watching the
news the other day and they they were it
was like a major news station was
talking about Brittany greiner's release
and they called her Brittany grinder I'm
like she's not an app she's not a
grinder either she's it's Griner like
how do you who screwed this up in the
typing in is this like an auto correct
thing anyway well the Chatham I think
spelled correctly now yes County
Sheriff's Office is trying to return the
bike that roach took neighbors have
offered to repair the bicycle or buy the
owner a new one I love this now great so
this is what I love if the bicycle is
yours you can contact the Chatham
spelled differently again County Sheriff
I'm not joking at
615-792-4341 my dream is that someone in
the dumb people Town World sees the
picture knows whose bike this is gets it
back if you do lettuce happens you have
to let us know you'll get a better bike
now you get a better bike you're gonna
get a better bike you'll get two pedals
and Steven Ellis will drop it off it's
not your house leave his baby video
because I have a new machine on the
marble countertop look out my window and
said what am I doing here this guy's
pulling up on my lawn he's living alive
this is a waterfall ledge counter
you don't need to know that backsplash
is the same as the don't worry about it
it's all one piece we had it all cut at
a season it's Caesar Stone whatever
anyway here nor there uh that's Story
number one man I love it there you go
first story now in the books we come
back after the break we'll find out what
Fortune's doing how you can follow
Fortune fiends or great support follow
watch uh live performances movies she's
in so much stuff I'm so excited uh we'll
do that after the break we'll let you
know what we've got going on it's down
people Town don't go anywhere
hey guys welcome back to the show uh
before we get into all the great things
that fortune is doing and how you can
follow and support her uh I believe this
is going to come out in January yes this
will be out in January either second
week or third week in January the 10th
of the 17th we got big news uh we are
all Randy and I uh if this is before the
18th through the 21st we're going to be
in Denver Colorado at uh Comedy Works
County works the South South Club yeah
big clubs so come on out if you want to
see us there and then the first weekend
of February we're going to be in San
Diego at the American Comedy Company and
then on Sunday flying up to San
Francisco because Sunday night one night
only one show only we're doing live dumb
people town at Cobbs Comedy Club I
believe Rob hubel is in To Be Our Guest
he's checking his production schedule I
would love it if he was the guest he
wants to do it so hopefully him and
maybe we'll add another but the point is
this is a 20th year anniversary of
sketchfest we were there at the very
beginning first and second one second
one we've been doing it for decades this
is I think the last uh one of the last
shows of the whole festival
you've done sketchfest have you in SF oh
it's so fun did I do it I think probably
maybe once yeah it's really hold it over
several weekends and so this is the very
last weekend actually I don't know if I
have you should do it I just need a
clusterfest no I don't think I've ever
done this yeah
yeah uh it's super super fun so so come
check us out San Francisco come see all
of us at cops it'll still be the most 7
30 February 5th cops Comedy Club San
Francisco we'll see you then and Daniel
you got stuff too at danielvankirk.com
yeah go to danielvankirk.com every
Wednesday at the lyric Hyperion theater
it's the lyric Comedy Hour with Myself
and Irene too and uh you can go every
Wednesday and see me do that show
hosting it with other great Comics every
single week and then I'll be in um uh
Denver for sure in April but
everything's up at Daniel Vancouver I
love it Fortune where can people see you
where can they see stuff that you've
done that's listening all that stuff I
just had a Netflix special come out
called good Fortune uh came out yeah
recently it so there's that one and the
sweet and salty one was the one before
that I'm doing a whole new tour that
starts the end of January going awesome
tons of places where can people find all
the dates fortune.com fortuner.com go
see her she's so fun and so sweet I love
that you're like I'm just working on
brand new material I don't know if this
works and you crushed and it was so fun
and I was like God there's stuff in
every single one of these things thank
you yeah hang on to those those are good
oh yes that you know that's that part
where this I'm going back on tour sooner
than I would normally I'm not giving
myself a ton of time to work out this
material so I'm in like high gear right
now trying to think by the way I think
you could probably do a bit or two from
Europe yeah I might throw in a couple
like I wouldn't like don't you don't
have to have a hole No One's Gonna
because there are people I'm sure
right who haven't seen the Netflix
special who brought someone was like you
gotta see her do this bit well in the
last tour because we had all that time
at home I did not do any old materials
so yeah and a bunch of people had like
sweet and salty shirts and stuff on and
I didn't do anything from that special
and they were bad maybe I'll do it
we're giving you permission we grabbed
permission no but I mean it's true like
says Comics were always like well we
gotta do yeah it's like the opposite for
bands like if you go to a concert to
your favorite band and they're like
we're gonna do the new album tonight
instead everyone's gonna be like [__]
what yeah no I want to hear the hits
well I hope so I'll throw in a few hits
but yeah I had to go back on the road
sooner because I'm I was filming this
crazy action series uh in Toronto uh and
that show comes out sometime in 20 are
you allowed to say who's in that with
you uh yeah it's uh Arnold
Schwarzenegger is the main uh personally
and uh we're hoping we'll be back next
summer we don't know yet so we're was he
fun to work with oh so fun so fun did he
know your comedy oh yeah we we watch you
do comedy oh yeah you like posted about
my he posted on his Instagram about my
special and put it he does like a big
newsletter I mean these are millions of
people that yeah watch uh listen not
listen read his newsletter that are just
a part of it and uh yeah so he's like I
bet you get a bunch of new fans from his
fans maybe I mean he's so beloved
especially internationally you know so
like he here's how beloved he is he had
a marginal governorship in uh which
would sink a lot of people be like oh
man he he still loved it's almost like
who cares you were the guy and he still
acts kind of like the governor he just
shakes hands he's the chief of staff
he's very uh he he does like tons of
volunteer work like he's cool we went to
his house in October and is he we're
like up in Carmel where does he live no
he's in L.A and then uh he has all these
like cool
um thing he he you know he's been in all
these iconic movies of course and he has
like stuff from those sets
in a planet
the chicken fingers were amazing and I
got to hold code in the Barbie and I
haven't been to his office but I think
he said his office has even more of
these cool movies not only from his
movies but a bunch of like in his office
he has a stuffed version of wheelchair
stop let's get into this story
fortunebeamster.com go see her live and
all the good stuff she's doing okay you
ready for this yeah this was sent in by
Beck s at Dr BX underscore okay Dr Bex I
don't think we've done this yet sure and
also we should remind everybody we are
we are doing this we've said YouTube a
couple times it's going to be on uh all
things comedy's YouTube channel will
probably it'll be its own playlist there
you can go and listen so go and
subscribe and like all of these and if
you're watching us for the first time
because you you stumbled acrosses
through the channel you can send in a
story to us like you are our dumb
reporter dumb boots on the ground uh the
way you do that as we said earlier it's
just through Twitter and you can do uh
at Daniel Van Kirk at our brothers
hashtag dumb people town we try to pick
whoever sent it in first okay
Fortune Dance Jay are you ready for this
yes
Cabrera home invasion trial is that the
Italian restaurant yeah that's if you go
to Cabrera's you get the carbonara just
we had a one didn't we have a casa
guerrado so there there was a there was
a Mexican restaurant in St Louis which
no better place to get Mexican food then
you know the landlocked center of the
country there is not one Mexican person
all right so uh
which we're like is Gallardo like
this is
watching a cheerleading competition on
cheap seats and the cheerleaders were
dressed like they were magicians to
which we The Magicians at a Mexican
restaurant which we were saying there
should be a Mexican magic restaurant
called Casa cadavers all right we got
there
to the airport a couple of times
would you are these Tostitos tostados
that's great
you want to see these fidgets get your
checkbooks out you want to see these
fajitas stop smoking boom boom can bear
a home invasion trial abandoned as
doubts linger over identity of the
perpetrators this is such an interesting
point so they're being tried but now
they're stops are lingering over are
these the perpetrators this is such a
crazy story and there are so many
moments here okay a criminal trial about
a violent home invasion that involved a
conf confrontation over a cheesecake
so say that to me again a violent a
violent home invasion that involved a
conversation over time this didn't
happen in a New York Deli
it was B Arthur has abandoned wait
somebody got in a fight over a
cheesecake and it's been the trial has
been abandoned due to confusion over the
burglar's identities okay you ready for
these names yeah Upper Crust James
Gregory Elliott three first names yeah
jge and Corey and Jackson Corey Allred
which are three last names yeah I think
you should like combine the name if I
said his name was Gregory Jackson or
Elliott Cory both these boys feel like
they were punched up James all right
you put on those all red shoes so it's
really comfortable have you had the all
red coffee it's amazing have face
charges of aggravated burglary
aggravated robbery and damage to the
property over an incident in the South
Canberra suburb of Chisholm so I think
this is where
Australia
give him the air in the baby thank you
sir and when we get a walkie-talkie I
want to I want to do I want full
walkie-talkie talk I want like CB over
and come back Aaron for guys and then
we'll go go for guys go for it and then
and then he'll say it over yeah just the
whole time be like what channel are you
on are you on one or you want to watch
how many times what channel are you on
what's your team we're on two anyway all
right so the ACT Supreme Court not the
ATC all things comedy Supreme Court the
ACT Supreme Court this week they do the
test Supreme Court this went all the way
up to the Supreme Court okay wow I heard
this week versus cheesecake the two men
allegedly forced their way into a unit
through the garage door at about what
time on July 7th 2020 so what time did
they force their their way I never
forget where I was on seven seven eight
thirty p.m 8 30 p.m what do you think
it's just 1am just past dinner I mean
it's time for cheesecake
the cheesecake hour
cheesecake or there was a fight over
cheesecake as these people were standing
I'm gonna get into it
you said three a.m 3 A.M get your
answers sorry I was just thinking of uh
Matchbox 20 something yeah
all right uh this is how at what time on
July 7 2020 the conversation they all
busted in through the unit through the
garage door at 10 pm she was right she
was right
prosecutors said one of the men pointed
a gun at the resident who was in the
garage and demanded his car keys wait
the guy in the garage demanded the other
guy's car keys this is bad riding no
okay point of the gun and demanded his
car give me your car keys yeah right
your money and hydro set I don't know
Hydro said I guess maybe is that weed
it's made something for a car I don't
know maybe it's like boots cars go
faster
this year's Christmas crazy
yeah I'm gonna be like okay yeah while
the other man allegedly hit him on the
shoulder with a machete okay hold on now
one part of them it must have been the
flat blade yeah right the thing I know
I'm hoping because it's a hit he hit him
he still has his own so give the guy a
chance to give you the [__] keys yeah
he's like ow oh good luck I can't use
this arm away from my response you know
what now you have to get the keys all
right I'm bleeding how am I gonna ride
my hydro set now right the okay so the
court heard that Mr Elliott and Mr Elrod
that went in the home where they were
confronted by another man
this is so great who was visiting the
victim so this is just someone who's
visiting okay and cooking a cheesecake
oh that's okay nice home yes right first
of all basically cookies I think it's
big baking and cheese like if someone's
cooking what are you making on that on
the grill up there
just barbecuing I'm grilling a
cheesecake wait yeah because because
doesn't it set like in the fridge like
you're not a fortune if you came to
visit my house and stay in my house and
you were in my kitchen with the bay
window and you said uh and you started
messing around the kitchen what are you
doing and you're like I'm cooking I'm
cooking a cheesecake you're doing it
wrong
you you can why are there so many things
you got onions in it this is the best
because
no
prosecutor Beth Moore uh Morris Rose
said that the visitor had a large
carving knife and allegedly said to the
pair this is the quote that puts it in
dumb people Town yeah well you [__] my
cheesecake game on
that's like a movie that sounds like a
movie this sounds like a Schwarzenegger
brought a kitchen knife to a machete
fight or you brought a machete knife to
a kitchen if he's got a big old butcher
knife that's this guy gets the machetes
he really loves cheesecake the court
heard the two men then stole a portable
safe and left through the garage before
kicking down the unit's front door so
these guys screwed it up in every
possible way yes they left through the
garage but kicked down the front door
they stole a safe yeah
affordable safe the victim was then hit
a final time before the pair allegedly
stole his mother's handbag and ran away
come to her so many things brought into
this yeah I was just waiting for a
cheesecake okay and the witness tried to
cook that thing yeah you gotta cook it
up you got to cook it good you gotta
flip it a witness allegedly saw the men
leave the unit in the mid-2000s white
Holden Ute with a damaged tailgate and
missing Grill so you have a lot of
things wrong with this car and it you
basically are saying we're gonna get
caught yeah it's a lot of easy easily
pointable you know yeah just look for a
car without a grill that's like you've
now narrowed it down to six in the area
and that's it police say they found the
Ute at another home in the same suburb
about about an hour later yeah okay I
know Jay I got that officers told the
court they found the two accused inside
that home
someone cooked this really nice in the
home so that's I guess this is their
home made so now they're back at their
house maybe I like it and uh that Mr
Elliott had a smear of blood on his hand
are we sure that's not strawberry juice
strawberry sauce what's the best
cheesecake you've ever had Dan
oh I like a good like like uh you know
it's like they call it Turtle Sunday
caramel and like oh yeah oh Cheesecake
Factory is still still is still doing it
I think their menu is too small
if they had a few more options I would
go there but there's I remember when
they put like 5 000 more calories on an
already large calories
do you like put peanut butter do you not
care you can't care you can't care you
just I'm there I'm there for the five
cheese pasta add chicken Penny Noodles
and store that cheese on there so please
say that they found another home in the
suburb and that officers said that okay
they found that please search Mr and
allegedly found keys to the Ute between
his clenched buttocks yes so this guy
you try to eat cooked cheesecake with
key stuck between his butts they found
him in Nature's pocket what everything
about this is in his books
that's where the safe is
[Laughter]
handbag the safe and imitation handgun
and a machete which had DNA on it
consistent with the victims yeah how are
these not the guys
the court heard that there was no
question the home invasion took place
right whether the two accused were the
men who carried it out he's got the keys
between this to me is like yeah an open
and shut buttocks case right here are
there uh other guys with three names
that would be the argument right the
only defense you have is that like we've
always been at this house someone else
brought all this stuff here yeah we were
every year everything we aren't the same
two guys okay in the police interview
the victim initially said he thought he
recognized the eyes of one of The
Intruders as a friend from high school
no I wouldn't say friend I know wow a
man who was not one of the accusers this
is where he was like voted most likely
to rob my house so I steal my cooking
she had the sexiest eyes in high school
sure uh I think it was I think it was uh
well it was a smokey eye probably
nationalization maybe what what had
happened at the time to try and cope the
victim said later this is so weird but
so he thought the eyes reminded of a
high school which is different than
these two guys who had all the evidence
that's what happens the handbag Keys up
the butt the whole thing is what happens
in trauma your mind tries I don't know
well it's inside his butt that's for
sure it's inside somewhere but
prosecutors dropped the charges
Wednesday and the trial was abandoned
because of questions over the identity
so these guys get to steal again old
machete all because the victim said I
these aren't the guys that eyes it
reminds me these aren't the eyes of high
school he let his own at what point do
you say what are we doing tomorrow
which is the person who's visiting what
do you want to do tomorrow yeah yeah we
can cook some more cheesecake how many
people have ever visited your house and
then started making anything yeah at 10
pm it's let alone a cheesecake
it's so presumptuous
so I was so we had we were at a party
and and at the RV the karaoke which is
the most fun thing ever at our friend
Sam's house and the super drunk
girlfriend of a friend of a friend was
there and she was so drunk yes I
remember this
he had postmated a taco to his house and
she goes into and it was his the guy
whose house it was so generous to let
people there and she's like whose Taco
is this she's really drunk and he's like
that's mine I always don't eat that I
ordered I'm looking forward to eating it
and she's like can I just have it he's
like no you cannot have this Taco so she
then this is how drunk she is one taco
order right a one taco post made that
[__] to me and I wanted delivered on a
gold plate one taco take off one of the
the cut and also that drunk logic that
ubereats order was 3.50
and ten dollars
for the drunk logic when you're being
you've already been told a thing yeah
you want to have other things
you can't just have it no no there's no
more information
she gets like this she's great you're
gonna love her just let her have it I
don't want you to give her a Doritos
that's my girl she asked she asked
that's on YouTube yes here's the best
thing that leads to what we're talking
about here is that when she was denied
the taco she started opening up his
cabinets to try and make food yes like
put took out a pan and took out a pot
this is at a party late at night
everyone's like what are you doing you
never invite people to your house what
are you doing don't you just walk over
to hurt the person she's there with she
also could have Uber eated
fur with a drunk person be like your
Taco's on its way yeah yeah like no that
one's like yours I ordered one for you
gotta wait out front yeah
wait two houses over and then call them
probably go down to the corner who was
her who was with her was someone with
her oh yeah yeah why don't you go to
that person to go ahead I think she's
got a handle at this point and by the
way if it were a woman and her boyfriend
or boyfriend I don't care who it is oh
yeah we said to you got to handle your
partner yeah you gotta handle this
person
I think I give a good stern look and I
go I think it's probably time to go yeah
right
I'm answering the questions
I think we're probably done yeah
essentially what that person was who
brought this drunk woman is like someone
who thought their dog could be off leash
inside of a restaurant and you were like
she'll be fine she'll be fine and then
she just starts eating everything she's
up on our [__] table ran through the
mud and is on our confidence
[Laughter]
everyone better be out
naked naked eating a taco and jerking
off all right uh that is Story number
two in the book oh we're doing the
transition give us a give us a little
taste of what we're gonna hear in Story
number three Jeff
um a cloud
leaves a town in bewildered stitches I
love it all right that is it uh you guys
and we're doing a new style of patreon
that's for you guys you send in your
stories to us it's a dptpodcast
gmail.com I believe that's what it is it
should be posted up there right it
should be posted up there but you send
in your story or if you found a story
before 2005 because that means we never
you really want them to be your story
though I know because I know whatever
you can but I'm we're gonna pick we're
going to pick up so but just send in it
if it's interesting even if it happened
in your town you have a connection to it
send it to us and that's we're going to
break down for our patreons but we have
one more story to go it's no people Town
Fortune p.m sir don't go anywhere all
right stick around
hey guys welcome back to the show The
Great Fortune themester is our guest we
are here on our new set for those I love
this set I love this set don't you check
out her special Good Fortune we talked
about that in the last but yeah sweet
and salt sweet and salty great we're on
the old Netflix I've heard of it fire up
the old Netflix and get it all right
final story I'm gonna take you guys home
uh here's the headline it's just sitting
by Carlene McDermott
Carly one of our favorite people who
says she's
prolification she contributes a lot of
dumb she's not dumb she's not dumb but
you know like she should get a dumb
pension when she retires you know how
much people go to thrift stores and like
they're like we went through the
Goodwill bins and we just my daughter
goes to the Goodwill bins she's like I
dug through everything and like you just
have to be good at sourcing this stuff
she goes through the dumb bins and pulls
it up all right here's the headline
giant penis shaped cloud leaves locals
and stitches with stiff breeze jokes
folks
and folks a local Facebook weather our
service has become the butt of the job
are they trying is this isn't the butt
of the joke I don't think so the butt of
the joke after it posted a picture of a
cloud that looks like a penis okay the
forecaster worn locals what's so fun I
mean it is funny that that's what it is
that it looks like a penis but also like
no one created that and also how long
did it look like a penis for right 10
seconds yeah there's a thing when you
like see something that you try to get
somebody to look by the time I'm gonna
show you this picture well once you take
a picture of course but I'm just saying
as it's happening you have like maybe a
minute so then someone takes a picture
of it and posts it and you're like okay
this is the greatest thing ever like
maybe there are chemtrails right for
forecaster warned locals that the warmth
seem to finally be fading with colder
temperatures penetrate no sneaking in uh
colder temperatures I I know the
barometric pressure is rising right now
this cloud shaped snapped by a local
weather service was a little bit
different seemingly obvious to the
phallic nature of the cloud Canterbury
Highway and weather information and said
our lovely warm weather comes to an end
with a southerly southerly hitting
tonight to bring a bit of rain nothing
too crazy so this giant penis is going
to spray all over this town oh my God
does it look like a dick
was the weather
um Channel or whoever did it were they
in on the joke or they just posted yeah
they I'm sure they posted they do make
joke all right so jokes it finds up a
little Thursday and Friday before some
more drizzle Saturday each leaves for
the rest of the long weekend then it's
long weekend long weekend then it should
warm up again next week the good people
of Facebook specifically those who are
enthusiastic about weather in Canterbury
who are those people
that's like the people hey Fortune what
are you doing after you cook that
cheesecake you're on Facebook you're
looking at the Canterbury weather what
does Aunt Sally do these days Dan she's
on Facebook yeah she's in a weather
group right yeah I mean thank God I
don't have any
let's talk about weather we look up the
weather in Canterbury
yeah yeah
they said uh the large cumulative is
that would be a smaller cloud in our
otago said Chilly Willy bit colder down
there a Chilly Willy that's a person are
you just reading Facebook Facebook
just make fun of them and jokes is in
quotes
looks like this southerly is coming in
hard and going to give us a real
pounding I don't feel like that's what
they're saying I want you to look at
this yeah
that's a penis it looks like that's a
large upwards right at his point well
it's not even just that it has the base
yeah it has a base it looks like uh if I
knew what a wiener looked like it looks
like
it looks like a dildo is what it looks
like oh my God yeah it definitely from
what I've heard of penises I mean it's
got curvature it's pointed upwards yeah
it's got the little it's got the base on
it too yeah it
and then the bottom there's like a
bottom part I guess would be the
testicles yeah but would be the balls
that would be the balls so but this is
this a gift or is this a nightmare like
who it is on who you know yeah this all
fortunate would be like you know what
this is
yeah exactly this is a lot of people
that would be a pain this is the porn
version of nope yeah this is have you
guys seen nope I've seen nope yeah you
only the first half
have you seen it oh this is a deep not
even deep cut that would it could be
that he is cut
um if you see nope you are in line with
that truck I know I can't compete with
the Facebook comments yeah but um that's
yep that's yes from the movie yep that's
a it's a pretty day in that picture it
gorgeous day beautiful day ruined by a
giant penis cloud like if a tornado
sometimes the universe gives you a gift
like sometimes the clouds and then
Facebook ruins it with dumb comments
right that's that's the Sabbath so
Facebook once again ruined a beautiful
fun thing I mean if if I'm driving with
my kid and I see a sky we're gonna laugh
the way you described this picture
you're seeing a big giant Club seems to
be like what a beautiful dumb thing yeah
gorgeous look what I don't believe in
God but if I did believe in God look
what she did look what she did for us
that is a moment where there are a
couple moments in this like Randy and I
don't believe in like telepathy between
the two of us but there was or or twin
coincidences sure one time though we
were driving to we said this on here
drive to the airport and uh both of us
were driving from our separate places
and both of us just had there's an
explanation for this no but I peed
before I left the house anyway so we
speaking of the penis Cloud no uh we
always call each other just to make sure
the other ones are you up are you going
to the airport because we got to go do
this gig if you overly check on each
other yeah Randy called me and I said
you're like half my but you're like my
paycheck depends on depends on you
getting up this is the dumb part of like
this is like what turtle and Entourage
yes like you know so so I didn't answer
the phone why because I had to pee so
badly and I was only 10 minutes from my
house
and I there's no gas station no nothing
nearby I went into a 7-Eleven and the
guy said you know what 7-Elevens are
they don't have bathrooms I'm like yeah
so I walked around the building in
between two apartment buildings okay and
knelt down like I was praying to God and
Pete oh you did a low a low low to the
ground I figured someone saw me there
it's five in the morning no one's gonna
say anything I watered the plants fine
then I get back and I'm like where the
[__] are you you guys worried that I'm
not up I call him he doesn't answer his
phone so he's like where am I I had to
pee and I went between two buildings and
had to pee so that's like this kind of
that's like the penis cloud in the sky
yeah every once in a while there's like
God gives us some large that gives a
gift would be like God gave this gift
you're welcome you're welcome in that
wild that that happened yes and that
kind of weird that's a great way to end
this uh some sort of twin thing yeah
yeah
everyone has their own pieces
May the giant penis cloud in the sky
bless you with good weather good fortune
and good happiness right there you go
yeah that is a show and oh [__] guys we
gotta get back to work we love you guys
and we'll see you next time
boom that was great thank you awesome
they're amazing thanks for having me
[Music]